today's topic
me and preach who are both on this so
there's a discussion surrounding
working women girls who
work in the bedroom professionally and
they were saying why they didn't want it
to be legalized and so they asked me and
preacher's thoughts and this is what
happened picture this though right we're
dealing with these girls behind the
scenes in person right
how they look at these guys that are
paying
it's different for what they're telling
you in person because they look at you
as okay he's paying a need that i have
but i don't respect him and for me
i don't want to bitch's [ __ ] i want her
soul
you ain't getting nobody's soul the [ __ ]
you think you are ghostbusters this man
said herself
look at your face right now you're
looking at the camera like what is he
talking about i don't know where the
whole soul's comment came out like this
you want a soul that's corny that's
super recording but anyways i don't know
i want that respect
like i don't mean the guy behind the
scenes where she's oh baby i love
whatever and then she's showing me oh
look all these turtle guys in my dance
want to pay me for sex like i don't
think i got behind the scenes i'm not
the guy that i should pay for it and you
talk about the respect
let me ask you something all the girls
you smashed yeah if i talk to every one
of them you think they all respect you
are going to say good things about you
yes all of them all of them you know
okay okay you know the best part the
live stream chat during that period they
were going crazy i know yeah they were
just going cap that's a lie
i'm sorry okay i don't care who it is i
don't care what if you're out there and
you've been with enough people
eventually you're gonna have people who
are talking [ __ ] about you behind your
back oh
even if it's not true it doesn't matter
you think all your exes are saying
wonderful things about you think
everybody you went on a date with saying
wonderful things about you know rough
you guys run a podcast
where you're talking about ladies all
the time controversial opinions there's
no way the women that you've been with
all of them have positive opinions about
you it's impossible it's impossible and
this whole idea that having game makes
you a better man that's also not true in
some instances it does great things for
you helps you develop confidence and
some good things fantastic but it also
turns a lot of people into shitty people
it does that's why there's a lot of
shitty ass pickup artists who are
terrible human beings this whole idea of
living your best life no listen gluttony
whether it's money or sex it's not a
good thing for a person
about me right now i'm a little bit
different because when i meet a chick
right
she would never know that i'm rp aware
because i was so chill and so cool that
like when she leaves my presence she's
like yo damn where's the guy
because real talk i'll [ __ ] [ __ ]
take her to eat some dinner she's her
belly's full she's feeling good good big
deal babe text me when you get home
she's like damn that was amazing time
did you pay for dinner
and you know the killer thing is like
whether they're paying with money or
you're paying with your time everyone's
paying for sex everyone pays for it you
pay you pay with your time and attention
that two three hours that you put into
that date most people put about five
hours minimum especially if you're
sleeping and minimum yeah right that's
time you could have put into work
putting out one or two podcasts you're
paying everyone pays we all pay but but
see that experience with me it's
priceless so she told the moment bro
you're gonna tell me you're gonna tell
me in my face you're gonna tell me in my
face that you just felt i don't wanna i
don't want her [ __ ] i want her so
broadcasting
on internet and you're going to tell me
that all these girls going to have
respect
you know some of them watch this you
left [ __ ] you left because
listen there's a lot of reasons what
else you want me to do you
no
mother gonna say nonsense no no because
me i'm special i move so smooth yo
believe what you're saying but go talk
to all these ladies some of them will
not return your messages some of them
will not want to talk to you some of you
so some of them blocked you but so we
came up with a couple of reasons some of
the bigger ones was um the girl's not
going to respect you on the same level
you're not going to get that genuine
desire bedroom fun
you're going to get that transactional
fund which for some guys that's good
enough number two she ain't gonna
respect you [ __ ] people go on your show
and disrespect you for free
and you kick them out isn't that true
that's true so it's like this whole idea
you gonna get respect from these ladies
if you don't
that's not true at all that's not how it
works that's not true at all but anyways
and then number three what i've
experienced with a lot of guys since
we've coached like hundreds if not
thousands of men at this point is a lot
of guys that uh do this all the time and
pay for it what happens is they start to
have a very
negative uh uh feeling towards women we
have a deep deep resentment towards them
towards them because they kind of see
the dark side of female nature with that
where they don't they can no longer look
at women with the same objective lens
they start to resent them and hate them
because they're like i have to pay this
girl my hard-earned money to get any
type of attention from her and they
don't really experience uh the benefits
that come from dealing with women and it
gets they get it gets them very jaded
okay all right so he said a lot right
there
what are your thoughts on the first
three points no guys are going to feel a
lot of resentment actually most of the
clients that these women have
don't represent them
they know that they know that it's on a
regular like it's on a transactional
basis and that's why they're there most
people most clients that go see them
girls know that and that's that and
that's it yes there's gonna be a couple
of weirdos but it's just like any
customer service kind of job you're
gonna see weirdos anywhere and there's
gonna be people that don't respect you
because you do customer service you
think you work at the mcdonald's all
your clients are going to be pristine
work the midnight shift and tell me
about that the people go there they
don't like you they don't respect you
the disre
and for what minimum wage there's a lot
of women who are dating dudes who don't
respect likes or don't like them there's
a lot of women who are just out there in
the dating world getting disrespected in
shadow exactly why are we talking about
this like it's any worse or better
exactly you want to talk about
resentment towards lady the red pale
community's got enough of that and a lot
of these dudes are not paying for it
there's plenty of reasons why people
might resent the other gender paying for
it i don't think is one of the reasons
for exactly the first thing he says you
won't get her best you'll get
transactional rather than genuine desire
or whatever it is there's some people
that are very professional at what they
do they give you that experience because
that's what they do when it comes to
world play the way he's talking is very
unidimensional and very it's not
reflective of that world no it's not
reflective of that world he's just
seeing it from outside and he's seeing
it from probably someone that has
resentment
from those people that that don't even
know that don't even look to find out
but whatever that's just speculation so
i'm not gonna go on that but
it seems like that but i'm gonna i'm not
really so much gonna spend some time on
that because that's how he thinks that's
how he thinks at the end of the day he
knows but it's very unidirectional
that's not what the reality is and how
it reflects it at the end of the day
when you pay someone for a job
they come to do it they're doing it for
free or they do not a passion they don't
always do a good job as an artist you
know this
ask an artist to do something out of
love and then ask a daughter to do
something because they're getting paid
the approach is completely different and
the truth is the reason why these high
value dudes or dudes who got all this
money paid for this is because they get
the best out of these ladies they get
the best out of them
when they show up they show up on time
they don't get flaked on when you're
paying somebody you get flaked on you
ever had somebody ghost you for a date
that happens right when they show up
they make sure everything's taken care
of because they're there to cater to
their client everything has got its use
a lot of these dudes are married they
have their wives at home but when they
want to get their rocks off or want to
get it good their wife can't always do
everything they need even though that
woman loves them and desires them so by
that logic you go to the restaurant
you're not going to get the best because
it's transactional
no you go to restaurant it's
transactional
it's better that you know well you know
a home-cooked meal is better there's
some pretty good restaurants out there
oh yeah that their food it's
transactional
the service is good the person smiling
they're getting paid the waitress that
should go to have a drink it's
transactional she's not really your
friend but she's there and while she's
there and getting paid she's herself
because she knows that she might get
extra same thing same thing my mom is a
wonderful cook i love ethiopian food
she's some of the best best ethiopian
food that's it the best
she can't make sushi i i tasted that i'm
going to see yamato so he can make the
sushi for yup okay suzuki he's making
the sushi for me great all right
ichimaru he's making the sushi for me
naruto he's making the sushi
they're not making sushi ichigo he's
making i'm just naming anime all right i
got that okay number two she ain't gonna
respect you and that's the other thing
the whole respect thing
not everyone needs that
as long as you're respectful in front of
me when i'm present that's great that's
all i need the second thing is a lot of
these women behind closed doors they
don't bottom out the people that they
get paid to do this stuff for women are
already talking [ __ ] about dudes that
they're just banging willy-nilly
they already talking [ __ ] about you they
talking [ __ ] about they man if you want
a bad breakup if you got a bad breakup
they talking [ __ ] about you if you do
something bad within a relationship and
still working they talk a [ __ ] about you
this whole idea of like they're always
going to respect you that's nonsense
that's crazy to me and also remember
this right when you're paying for the
peace leave or the p box what happens is
you get lazy so all the game is out the
window now because guess what now you're
relying on your money leading with your
wallet to get the girl yeah but once
again that girl's only there for the
money so there's no respect who cares
if you're only there for the sex why do
you need her to have burning desire for
you it's like let's not make it sound
like wanting to bang a girl's like some
noble cause that
deserves respect who cares but this idea
that like
oh they're only there for the money most
of the time we're only there for one
thing as well and it's very very like
instant gratification and then we're out
so i don't even understand why you would
want to have like some deeper approach
to it two this whole idea of having game
and all this stuff it's for some people
not everyone wants that not everyone
wants to bother going on dates and
chatting to women and being a player
it's not for everybody it's not for
everybody sometimes you just want to get
your rocks off sometimes you hit up a
booty call doesn't require any gain it
doesn't
but you do it because it's convenient so
this whole idea of having game it's not
for every man listen bruh back in my
young days right when i had to go up to
some ladies
ugh
the like just the work to put in it's
like why am i here it wasn't worth it
that's why when you get older you stop
you you you stop wanting to do that
because you're like
this ain't worth all the trouble the
word the way they talking about the game
is really it sounds really like [ __ ]
dungeon and dragon what you mean
not everybody want to play dungeon in
dragon you want to play uh
you know you get the game you don't get
the skills
some people don't want to play your
goddamn game i don't want that if i want
to eat some fish i don't want to go to
the river and fish it sometimes i want
to go to the market it's already cut
it's already gutted it's already washed
i just want to put it in the pan i don't
want to go fish for a whole day to have
look i'm proud i caught this boss i
don't give a [ __ ] let me go to the store
get this fish right quick
here's another one
if i'm into dominatrix stuff a random
hookup is a waste of my time straight up
all that work to find a girl who's not
into the stuff i'm into why would i
waste my time if you want specifics if
i'm just showing up for one night i'm
not here on tinder it got time to swipe
i'd rather just pay somebody show up and
we know what time it is you look
fantastic i enjoy having you as my
company for the date afterwards you go
back to the hotel we handle it there's
so many reasons why you would do it and
it's very logical for a lot of people i
personally enjoy chatting to links i
enjoy doing the whole process great
that's for me but just because some
ain't for me doesn't mean that other
people who are into other stuff are
[ __ ] readers some people want to do
you know virginity tell marriage it's
not for me but i'm mad at people who do
that and i'm like man you lack game
because you're waiting to
they got their own trajectory that they
want to go live not everyone is built to
do this all this stuff this whole
seduction thing that
it's not necessary for everyone but
anyways i'll keep going there's no
genuine desire and in this scenario
right here yeah i know you said some
guys are married and they go behind the
scenes whatever but deep down a man
wants to be desired by women and this is
why people pay for only fans because
they want the one-on-one with a girl
they want a genuine desire that's not
true even for me i don't care for girl
desires
sometimes i don't care
if i'm trying to date her seriously sure
sometimes i'm acting on a girl it's fun
to her to be but there's sometimes i'm
just like bruh you know what this is a
friends with benefits situation i enjoy
sleeping with you you enjoy sleeping
with me we don't have that much desire
for each other but it's convenient
that's some situations and for some
people that's perfect so this whole idea
of like you always need desire that's
not true at all so preach right i get
what you're saying
i actually know a lot of guys that pay
for it right and they're very successful
very wealthy but the problem is that
like they no longer see women
as a challenge it's kind of it's kind of
like not that they can get it by just
paying because they didn't 100 bucks
nothing 20 bucks nothing it's like paper
it's like a dollar to them now it's kind
of like okay now that i'm at this level
like women to me are like
how to put this
it's like
a piece of candy i can just go go to
store and buy it you know the irony of
this is
is that myron has an analogy about the
candy store
yes he has this whole analogy about like
you know the reason why men don't want
to settle is because our whole lives we
couldn't get into the candy store while
we watched the ladies go in and now that
i made my money i'm going to candy store
but you only told me to leave with one
candy's like no i've wanted to try all
the candies so it's interesting that
he's talking about like
how these rich men view these women as
candy meanwhile his partner got a real
analogy about viewing them as candy this
is interesting but now with that being
said
uh their game they have no game because
now it's kind of like okay you know what
today i'm lazy i just finished my
business meeting called took over to
smash and
just the mentality is is a very lazy bro
what's wrong if dudes don't have game
what's wrong if they just want to pay
for it smash and be like whatever
what's the issue with that what would i
think it's good that a lot of dudes do
have game but not everybody can have
game so what's wrong with some dudes
just being like man just throw the [ __ ]
i mean get the [ __ ] out of it i'll say
this right so this is something that is
gonna come to the person's uh nature and
what they really want out of life yes
and
not every guy needs game you're right
however
for you to live your best life while
you're here you do want a burning desire
now get this most guys don't understand
for example okay if i pay for it right
i'll get what i want but if they didn't
pay for it they get much more because
once again
i suspect these guys are paying a
hundred dollars for hookers
they're getting cheap end ones maybe
that's what's happening right it's like
a street walker if you pay high money
these girls come correct so what are you
saying about you're gonna get more out
of like some sexual it's not true at all
but anyways yes when you pay you get it
right away but you're not paying the
character you build the game that you
learn the strategy that that you kind of
like come up on you become a better man
the best sexually the best compliance
the best uh submissiveness and the best
res and more importantly for me respect
if you take care of the lady and you pay
it properly there's a lot of girls who
will do pretty much anything for that so
i agree with what you guys are saying
where even for me it's not how i want to
do things but for some guys you know
what you said like living your best life
some guys find it boring okay they they
start talking to them like ugh
they're putting effort they're just like
ugh
you know what i mean i get it especially
especially when you're busy hey listen
there's a lot of reasons why you should
legalize it considering it makes it
safer for the workers it brings tax
revenue to the country because this
stuff is already happening happens the
dm's it happens on the streets it
happens on websites it's happening every
day
right legalize it make it safer for the
workers and also uh you make it so that
the government gets his tax money gets
redistributed into the city whatever
okay there's a lot of advantages to it
the downsides have not been recorded in
places where it is legalized so so this
is my thing me personally i'm not into
paying but some people are and you know
what i should say
everyone should do what they want to let
them all right there's guys in marriages
right now who go to rubbing tugs because
they want a little something extra on
the side there's nothing wrong with it
let them all right everyone's doing
things in a safe and consensual manner
i'm all for it anything you want to say
no that's pretty much it yeah there you
go but that was a cap that's a big old
cat big old cat big old cat all the
girls respect me listen yo guys if i'm
lying about this guys post below you
guys honestly believe every girl you've
ever been on a date with or seen has
respect to you afterwards hindsight's 20
20. they remember things differently
they only remember the negative parts
after you reject them you all know that
you don't talk about yeah you say no to
somebody are you like you know what he
was an [ __ ] it's impossible well no
just no just stop
but hey maybe you're a magician maybe
you got the special game that nobody
else has but i don't buy it for a second
so
no cause me i'm different
[Music]
foreign